Brazil's presidential election will be
settled in a second round of voting on
October the 30th that's after no
candidate took an absolute majority of
votes on Sunday with nearly all of the
ballots counted former president Luis
inacio Lolita Silva who is simply known
as Zula has 48 while incumbent
received an unexpectedly strong 43
percent moderates is trading with four
percent
Lula spoke to supporters in the
commercial capital's El Polo putting an
optimistic spin on the result
I always believed that we would win
these elections and what I can tell you
is that we are going to win these
elections this is just extra time for us
the race has proven tighter than most
surveys suggested revitalizing incumbent
president xiu bolsonaro's campaign after
he insisted that polls could not be
trusted his surprising showing dashed
Lula's hopes of a quick win
think we will form a good alliance to
win the elections
well Cristiana emalio is from DW's
Portuguese for Brazil's Service uh tell
us a little bit more about uh this
result I mean we're going to have to
wait a little longer of course to see
what happens but were you surprised
yes completely surprised I guess it was
a big surprise for all the Brazilians uh
the polls the election polls show it a
very different
situation with Lula ahead from bolsonaro
with a big Advantage so now the analysts
are trying to figure out what really
happened I would say there was a higher
absence many people went one couldn't go
to vote
like 20 so I guess this could be because
many were fearing this political
violence and also we saw many cues long
long long time to vote so many people
probably just said we are not going to
wait so this changes maybe this results
Lulu is currently ahead he's LED Brazil
before but tell us a little bit more
about who he is yeah he's uh he was a
union union leader and a very popular
his government in Brazil was really he
left the government with a huge
popularity still and after being accused
of corruption he was in jail and then
after the Supreme Court decided that
this was not a fair uh judgment he was
freed and now he is the big hope for the
Brazilians to defeat bolsonaro the
followers from Lula believed he he would
be the right person to do that of course
you gave us a little bit of an idea
about the
the election atmosphere before
um what's the actual situation like in
Brazil at the moment what's the
political climate like uh going into
this next round of voting yeah there is
a big polarization and now it's going to
go still further the division in the
society I would say we could expect for
the second turn uh more political
violence
um more fear from voting also maybe
attacks against the media as we have
seen against the justice system from the
bolsonaro followers and I would say
that's it's it's now much more difficult
to Lula also to run for the second term
but at the same time we had other
candidates like Simoni Tabet she could
probably uh go now offer her his her
support to bosona to ulula and sorry so
I guess this could be he could Lula
should win much more support from the
other candidates too okay so I think
could be looking good for Lula not so
good uh for the voting atmosphere it's
not the sort of atmosphere you want
that's conducive to to a good election
but uh casiana thank you very much for
coming in and bringing us your insight
into this election thank you very much